So let's discuss the solution for our speedup
averaging quiz. We only have the speedups for the
two applications, and we have said previously that
an arithmetic average of speedups does not make sense.
You should not use arithmetic averaging for speedups,
because they are ratios of execution times. So the
only thing that does make sense to use
in speedups, in this case, is a geometric mean.
Thus, the speedup we need is a 2 times 8, and then there are two values,
so we take the second root of that. And we get a number 4. So the correct
answer here is the speedup is 4. Again, doing something like 2 plus 8 over 2 is
not correct here, because these are ratios. You
should not use the normal arithmetic mean for that.